اذا من الواضح ان المرحله القادمه في
الصين مشاهدينا وراويه ستكون مختلفه تماما
عما شاهدته البلاد منذ بدايه الوبر تكوني
طاهر المواجهه وكسر حواجز الخوف مرحله
جديده بالتاكيد خاصه وان المعني هنا هو
ثاني اكبر اقتصادات العالم وقد يكون الاول
وفقه التوقعات في 2030 ومن باب التفاؤل
اعتبرت صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه انا
خطوه رفع القيود هذه قد تحدد مصير
الاقتصاد العالمي بل وتنقذه من ركود
المحتمل كل المؤشرات اذا التي اورادتها
واشنطن بوست تؤكد انا عجله الاقتصاد
ستتحرك بسبب الصين خاصه وانه منذ خليها عن
السياسه الصفريه بلغت الذره والتفش
الفايروس في اقرب وقت من المتوقع بعيدا عن
الاسهم والبورصه يتوقع البنك الدولي نموا
بنسبه 4 فاصل اربعه هذا العام بالنسبه
للصين يقول محللون اقتصاديون ان
المستهلكين الصينيين راكه من خلال الحجر
في المنازل مدخراتهم
لثلاث سنوات وحان الوقت الان ليستمتع بها
بعد هذه السنوات العجاف حيث ارتفعت ارصده
البنوك الاسريه بنسبه
42% او 4.8 تريل يوم دولار منذ بدايه عام
علامات ذلك بدات تظهر جليا في توافق
السياحه الصينيين والوجهتان الاكثر
استفاده منهم هما تايلاند اما المدينه
التي يفضلها معظم الصينيين هي لوس انجلوس
في كاليفورنيا
وتتمتع بشعبيه عاليه بينهم ووافقه محركات
البحث فان التفتيش عنها تضاعف في الفتره
الاخيره اضافت الصحيفه ان شركه طيران
صينيتين هما التشاينا نعم ايرلاينز تخططان
لاستئناف الخدمه اليوميه بدون توقف بين
بكين و لوس انجلوس هذا الشهر ومن المتوقع
ان يصل ما يقرب من مليون زائر صيني الى
الولايات المتحده هذا العام ارتفاع من
359,000 العام الماضي وفقا لجمعيه السفر
الامريكيه
وسفاء سافر الصينيون او لا فان الانفاق
الاستهلاكي لن يقتصر على قطاع السياحه لان
الموجودين سيختارون تار فيها انفسهم
والعوده الى وجبات المطاعم المحليه
والافلام والاحداث الرياضيه وغيرها من
الانشطه الشخصيه التي كانت محظوره اثناء
عمليه الاغلاق بهذا الانفاق مشاهدينا هناك
عده علامات تجاريه امريكيه ستستفيد وعلى
راسها ستاربكس ويمبرانس ملكه سلسله مطاعم
كنتاكي الشهيره وغيرها وغيرها الكثير
[موسيقى]